all right all right hey what's going on
everybody and it's time for a very
special episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast i have a very special
guest who's out here on the west coast
yeah a man who likes his italian food he
likes his cigars cuban he likes his
second wife asian and he likes his
leather white
[Music]
likes a four-door sedan
and a pair of [ __ ] brand new right
out of the box jordan won please welcome
the one and only
mr paul verzi it's so good to be with
you buddy and i got to tell you
something right when you walked out
first thing of course i noticed is the
beard because this is the thickest i've
ever seen you had it yeah dude you're
looking younger skin is like kind of
hollywood baby yeah botox
how brutal i saw you and you're like
your lips were all fine
and i couldn't smile
oh god
it just came out like is this coming out
like this oh my what's going on
hey you know i heard the movie's doing
really well let's get in good reviews
oh my god no i'm so excited right now
oh my god i'm so sad
oh what kind of melancholy your face
just never changes in case you didn't
get what the bit was i got to tell you
something for the first time ever i knew
what you were saying because you know me
bill i'm not one of these east coast
guys at trash la a lot of guys [ __ ] it
out there it's but i actually enjoy my
california time i came around to it
that's not be crazy i never hated it
paul don't start off with a lie i never
start off with a [ __ ] lie you went in
on this town like all you guys doing no
all you guys all you guys doing
this little run down looking it's a
bunch of hipsters yeah yeah that bunch
of this
i know i knocking pizza steaks
i didn't see an albatross oh i haven't
had a pigeon there's no pigeon i haven't
had a great slice out here yet i haven't
had a great slice of pizza yet but i've
had great meals i haven't had good
mexican in new york you're in a
different place paul you go 3 000 miles
away the reason you do it right is to
experience something different right not
to get bore's head sandwiches or
whatever the [ __ ] you were talking about
oh uh boar's head meet yeah boys had me
this guy this east coast guy was excited
yeah boston right now and you're like
bill
i can get bored's head
down the street yeah but i'm trying i'm
trying to give your town a compliment i
will say i i like a great wall of china
bad slice of pizza did not have a good
slice of pizza ruined my whole trip
that's how new yorkers travel to the
louvre i swear to god it was
the worst italian i ever had in paris
[ __ ] horrible
did you try beef bourguignon what's that
it's what they do
dude i went to the eiffel tower the
gyros downstairs [ __ ] horrific
so
so um but i actually you know i enjoy my
time here and for the first time ever i
saw what you were talking about with the
driving because this is this is oh yeah
i got to do a bit on this because i've
never
called any talk to anybody on the phone
when they're in la and this is what you
hear yeah dude so my daughter's birthday
party would you [ __ ] go yeah
yeah we were at the christening the
priest was crying i'll [ __ ] kill you
it's it's and you go the driver's here i
saw a guy in the tesla get over that's
another one yeah yeah dude how's the
special doing this [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
this is what they do out here i don't
know if you can see this
all right i'll do it this way say here's
the car right here's a lane and here's a
lane when they go to get into this lane
and it's stop and go traffic like or
there's nobody there they'll they wait
to the last second to get in so they get
in and this part of their car right here
is still in your lane and you can't do
this because the [ __ ] out here don't
know this move you know that move like
yeah on the east coast you know
somebody's going to do it so you
anticipate their move you'll see it yeah
you do that they don't this [ __ ]
guy's i guess and you beep at him and
then when you drive by him they look at
you like what the [ __ ] because they're
so [ __ ] stupid or self-involved
they're like well i'm in the lane yeah
it's all about me it's like
the back third of your car isn't no
don't get me going no i saw a guy in a
tesla it was almost impressive how he
wasn't looking
i saw a guy a tesla x or whatever or why
the big one and he was dude it was so
blatantly not looking at the road to our
house i was like jesus
no they have both
the tesla has like a [ __ ] super sized
ipad
i don't know how you look at anything
other than that it's like the [ __ ]
screen in movies but if i had a dollar
for every time i was on the phone with
bill and it you've never not done it
i'll pull the drivers out i can't i
can't no because
on the surf surface streets which is
just not highways
they drive like [ __ ] you know like
they took a pot cookie but when they get
on the highway dude they drive like
[ __ ] maniacs it's the commuters yeah
every day
they moved outside of la so they could
get a decent house you know a pool and
all of that and then they got to do that
grind every day and every time there's
just a little bit of daylight they lose
their mind they just put the [ __ ]
throttle to the floor like they'll pass
you doing like 90. it's [ __ ] insane
yeah no i saw it out here and i actually
said to myself i kind of understand what
he's talking about hey paul what's up
with these la drivers is this [ __ ] crazy
this is am i crazy oh sorry i got the
phone on i never have the phone on
that's because i was waiting for a text
from you and you're important paul
means a lot you're an important person
so paul yeah what brings you out to the
west coast you got a project or two
you'd like to promote i i i've been
hearing things i've been hearing things
in the industry yeah man let me make
sure i promote this perfectly it's
pretty uh
it's pretty cool man um
we've come full circle
no uh yeah man special nocturnal
admissions on netflix is doing great man
killing it's doing i i
yeah i don't even it's amazing it's
people are loving it it's great and uh
you got the whole new hour and you're
crushing with that you're out here
there's a new comedy club in silver lake
i don't even know about that yeah i'm
gonna do yeah i'm gonna do an 80-seater
thursday night at eight o'clock and run
a new hour that i got going on what's it
called the hipster
no it's actually called the same guys
that
the same guys that do the new york
comedy club opened a replica smaller
version of the same exact style room
called california comedy are they
bringing the george silver lake are they
bringing the george foreman grill to
heat up your winners that you pay at the
register that was the old one
do that no the old new york comedy club
not this one
they bought it oh they bought it no they
saw what was going on and they were like
dude this is this got to go dude i
literally watched a woman handling money
and then reached over and either picked
up the foreman grill lid for a
quesadilla and people still ordered food
she was handling money
and i'm telling you when i say it was
like it was sitting there like you know
like when there's just a disheveled
character in a movie with like a desk
with like years of files on it that's
what that whole area looked like with
the cash register yeah in the middle of
it and it was funny this stool was like
too high for the register you know when
their knees are like you know up oh it
was a mess well it was a mess i remember
hearing dude the new year the new new
york times
is great and i go i don't know dude i
went there that was it doesn't they go
no you should and and he did a good job
so they opened one in silver lake and
they were like hey do you want to run it
in front of 80 people and i'm like yeah
let's go let's have a good time i
remember todd berry making fun of the
old one the foreman one and that they
had repainted the thing and he goes how
do you guys like the new paint they put
here
port authority men's room gray
dude oh my god it was just overcast in
the thing it was just
they didn't have one picture on the wall
that was the old one paul yeah and this
is a new one and this is hollywood glitz
silver lake used to be a place for
younger people and then those younger
people got a little older they got
married so now it's like you know
yeah like cooler parents i guess you
know in that area so it's a nice area
it's a it's an upscale area i remember i
had a buddy there uh and there's a place
that has good wings called the rustic
inn if i remember correctly yeah is it
called the rustic in i believe it's
called ye rustic he wrestles
congratulations to you too live at red
rocks crushing funny is that right you
know it's amazing i used to open for you
and now but special what'd you do if i
just [ __ ] bubbled this whole if i
just [ __ ] cried for five ten minutes
and then you laughed
my ass off like if it started out as an
emotional thing but then i just lost it
i couldn't go on i would hang in there
for 30 seconds trying to be a good
friend and then after a while looking
over at aaron like is this no i would
just think all the people watching and
what they were saying in the comments
and i would just start bursting out
laughing look how uncomfortable bill
looks and then that would be it
dude have i ever looked whiter i mean
look at look at on that [ __ ] thing
man i just been in an edit room
we're almost done paul how's it looking
uh it's looking great
it's looking great yeah so we got us we
got a uh
a screening
coming up
we're getting towards the end here and
then we lock the picture and then they
color it and then they put the sound in
the music and all of that [ __ ] and then
uh then it's football season paul oh
football he's coming on 40 pounds
gambling and eating [ __ ] wings oh
dude i can't not wait i cannot wait i
heard your boy jimmy g's coming to the
giants
to put a little pressure on jones that's
what i heard oh that guy the guy fell
down yes please
guys got wheels though but he's got
wheels yeah the guy from duke right yeah
yeah a guy from duke just out in the
open falling
i was rooting for him
that's up there with that white guy that
dunked and held on too long and flipped
we don't like like the you know like
that the black guy that gets the nfl but
he's like you know he's from like you
know like the worst part of the city he
just went through all his shits this
great like story like one of those
stories you see in the olympics that
your quarterback is like the white guy
version of that you know he went to duke
ivy league his parents were rich no one
said he could make it to the nfl
he kept it real as a white guy his dad
is a cic ceo of a fortune 500. he
committed a crime his dad's money got
him out of it and no one said he could
make it to the nfl and he did it
they saw his boat shoes and like this
kid can't play oh [ __ ] man um i'm
rooting for that guy
yeah i'm rooting for that guy just
because i don't you know
what's with new york comics
comics what's what's the deal
with new york quarterbacks they [ __ ]
run into people's asses they trip over
themselves i mean it's just it's been
what happened to joe willie in [ __ ]
why a tittle new york lost that the
knicks lost it in the 70s and yeah but
you had it back in the 90s
you just didn't win it dude the knicks
in the [ __ ] 90s was was amazing yeah
i guess jordan took jordan kind of nick
nicks that really i mean it's like all
like how many people would have had
rings if brady wasn't around
yeah dude he just got andrew jones not
andrew jones that's the guy from the
braves oh uh andrew yeah he's not even
playing anymore dude i know but he was
he did play in he didn't play for
atlanta for a long time julio jones
julio jones julio jones you got julio
jones this is going to be like [ __ ]
07 again when he had randy moss
julio jones a little past that but i
mean it's great to have him but oh he
had to go negative
no i don't want to burst your bubble but
like i got excited i'm like tom's going
to be throwing jones in here yeah
sorry did edelman back you have edelman
again who no edelman's retired are you
sure
i don't i've been in a [ __ ] cave for
three months what happened i thought i
thought i heard something that they
talked edelman into going but then i
don't i don't know you just don't bring
up to a patriots fan that maybe
edelman's coming i don't i need a
definitely i don't know what you with
tom brady who knows who's coming back
tom will talk about he's going to go to
tampa
yeah
like there would be edelman to tampa is
what i'm saying i heard or like they
tried to talk to him and then he i don't
know if so this is like tom cruise when
he left that [ __ ] agency in that
movie
and then everybody's coming with me
who's coming with me
no i don't know though he could have
just said no i i heard rumors of that
that they tried whatever you were trying
to do paul it worked you made me upset
[Laughter]
i haven't seen bill belichick's going to
tampa
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh i heard i heard he's going to retire
for a week and then go to tampa
i think tom is just telling him all the
money he's saving on [ __ ] state taxes
down there
did you hear what edelman said about
belichick he goes dude i don't even i'm
not even on that guy's team anymore i'm
scared of him he goes every time i see
him now he goes are you going to keep
doing impressions of me because he does
an impression of him and he goes i mean
for [ __ ] sake he said he goes i'm
still scared of the guy and he goes i
don't even play for him anymore i gotta
hear his impression of it yeah i guess
he gets real low like he does it and i
guess he did it on a sports show and
belichick saw him and was like are you
gonna [ __ ] keep and he and he said he
[ __ ] with him about it he goes i'm
still scared of the guy and they all
started laughing he was talking to these
ex nfl wide receivers and they all
started laughing they all started
laughing about that
um i can't i can't wait for that my uh
i'm hanging in there with my red sox
paul i'm hanging in that dude
nobody loves a last place team like you
you it's called being a fan you love
yeah no it is you love like hey it's not
over yet it might not be over because
you guys make runs like that with the
red sox
uh last year you made a run well sale
came back and then he immediately hurt
his finger yeah he got hurt
i'm worried about the yanks because the
yanks are winning but like i've been
paying attention the mets the mets got
us you guys have been going like this
lately all of a sudden the dodgers have
the best record in baseball you guys
have not been winning you lost to the
[ __ ] royals last night yeah but we
beat them i'm not nitpicking no no we
beat them two out of three did you we
beat them 220 million dollar team of
course you did oh well how much is your
[ __ ] we have to spend that because of
what you guys spend oh sure blame the
drug dealer for
[ __ ] drugs for bringing drugs into
the [ __ ] neighborhood
i love how your argument was you guys
are drug dealers like you're some sort
of like misunderstood
as soon as i said it i go this is
probably not the right answer no it's
george steinbrenner's legacy
i also think you know i i believe this
that that because everybody plays
that fantasy football and baseball and
all that and acts like a gm and is
always adding people to their fantasy
teams and it's been going on so long
that
pylon teams and all that type of [ __ ]
are just like nobody even like sees it
anymore
because i was talking i got a buddy of
mine yankee fan all my [ __ ] friends
at yankee fence and when that guy from
the uh
senators came up
turned down like three million the
nationals nationals sorry the senators
phil i love it
the senators
bills
jones bill's been [ __ ] named
the st louis browns they were the
washington senators twice they left the
first time they became the rangers the
second time they became the twins
mariano rivera is the greatest relief
pitcher of all time he wasn't when i
said it you got that manny ramirez
no man i said manny remember manny
rivera i'm going man i don't know this
guy um yeah that kind of well you know
the guy 450 million to not play my two
favorite yankees right now uh that oh
matt carpenter's got to be one of them
oh yeah the guy who looks like the state
trooper i love that oh dude he looks
like ron gibbs dude he's hitting bombs
too and he goes up with no batting
gloves he's a [ __ ] man paul these
guys come up they got this on they got
the [ __ ] [ __ ] they're hanging all
over the place yeah dude that guy walks
in like he just got done smoking a
[ __ ] joe camel right you want to barf
do you see what his pregame thing is his
pregame thing is he has shorts on just
like like i'm like just shorts
barefoot shorts and a t-shirt and he
just walks around the outfield for a
half hour just looking around here every
game he's just looking around the damage
he's getting he just looks around and
then he comes he looks like a guy at a
picnic in a field just looking around
and then he just goes in and his face
that and then who's your pitcher who
literally looks like dad they took it
from the stairs nestor cortez i love
that guy
yeah
yeah we went old school on a couple i
love dude my whole life i've loved
pictures that just look like you know
the the [ __ ] dad across the street or
something yeah you love that gaylord
perry cece sabbath yeah i always love
that you love a kid in a mustache
yeah but also a guy that looks like he
just [ __ ] throws gas and then goes
out and eats like a [ __ ] couple of
burgers i'm not pitching for a couple of
days let's go to hooters
dude wells you guys have had some great
hats sloppy so we had some sloppy i love
a sloppy picture because back in the day
they had all kinds of condiments and
[ __ ] all over them and they'd be doing
this and yeah doing that and [ __ ]
working the ball you had a couple of you
guys had a couple of uh no that wasn't
enough slow one kid on the mets dude oh
my god the kid on the mets looks like
they took him from the bleachers and he
won a contest to be in the game oh i got
to see oh my bill i i mean it's hard to
be like is this serious
one of my favorite moments in the last
like 20 years of baseball is bartolo
colon hitting that home run in san diego
and then i loved how all everybody like
went into the clubhouse because that's
the thing when you hit your first home
run it was like [ __ ] 25 years and
they ignore you yeah yeah and he just
kind of came out and they and then he
just literally sat down by himself just
like laughing and then they all came
running out and it's just like i i
[ __ ] i love [ __ ] like that i i i was
at the stadium i took lucas and i saw a
home run and it solidified
what we said where if you can hit the
game winning shot in game seven catch a
touchdown in the super bowl walk off
there's nothing better than than that
time alone around the bases would just
be oh god dude
that's gotta be you know because even a
soccer goal i wanna ask a major league
baseball player what's it like when
you're trying to stretch a single into a
double and you're halfway there and you
know you're going to get thrown out just
that [ __ ]
and then they all try to do like like
everybody's everybody's hip to this
slide where you come in and you go like
that like everybody yeah yeah everybody
knows you're gonna do it oh there's
nothing and then going now they're
wearing a [ __ ] mitten
yeah yeah what what more are they gonna
do but the the the offense and the the
pitching in baseball right now they're
in a hazmat suit
[Music]
a snow snowstorm
you know those sumo wrestler fat things
you come up there
no you go up in the moto gp riding suit
and if the ball comes near you it senses
it and the air bag goes up
um no there's uh um
i forgot what i was gonna say oh you
know the the the pitching is so good in
baseball now in the eras they're
actually talking about lowering the
mound
even more and i was joking in my podcast
uh the last episode that it's like an a
cup titties why do they keep
well how do they keep changing things
because because offense sells the game
and when you game you need your game
it's gotta be a river paul you know what
somebody said somebody goes stagnant
water people start getting sick some
some guy a major look at the game he
goes like this he goes yeah they say our
game's too slow our game's getting
boring [ __ ] you then don't watch our
game our game's great like leave the
[ __ ] game alone
well that would be three hours
that would be if people could just be
happy
with what they have right and people
aren't people always want more because
they're not happy yeah and if they would
just do mushrooms like me
no no i'm kidding um mushrooms did help
i said helped a lot yeah no that's i'm
not i'm not uh i got rid of a lot of
people i'm not i just started bawling
imagine we just both were crying
i'm sorry went through that um
no i said to somebody yeah i'm just
there are certain guys that are built
for it you know you know what i'm built
for bill i'm billed for first class
because that's all i do now you're going
to love that and i don't know if i could
afford it but you know what i'm not
going back it's so funny i'm not going i
remember that point in my career i'm not
going back i i when i moved out here and
i just said [ __ ] this i'll do business
i'll do businesses i was like [ __ ] that
i'm flying the front of the plane i
remember my first visa bill i was like
maybe it was like coach to the this side
of the mississippi riddle
i i i tried to go first too soon
too soon and i and i and at my [ __ ]
visa pill went from here to there and i
was just like all right i can't [ __ ]
do this i'm probably there right now
then i will i'm probably in first a
little too soon so i did tell the people
everybody knows you do the end zone
dance on the 20-yard line
i said like there's no doubt to me that
you're going to start flying first
before you should but that's what you
got your wife for yeah yeah yeah she'll
come in should i keep on listening we
love what you're doing on the team yeah
yeah just make sure the ball's across
the goal line i know before you hold it
up yeah i'm like stacey it's third and
one
i'm going over the top
uh my my team called me like the people
that booked me and she goes paul i can
get you in first class but it'll be
another thousand if you want to do it
and i i just bought in um two pairs of
sneakers at the mall for 600
and i go i just go stacey will kill me
let's just do business
that was smart yeah especially if you're
trying to fly first class prematurely
and you say words like bottom
bought yeah you just bought you said i
just bought it i just bought it you said
i just bought in two players yeah we're
gonna have to listen back but maybe i
thought you were talking about botany or
something no no but there's a lot of
times i can't afford the first class but
when it goes up to the ones where they
got the beds and [ __ ] you know they're
like uh it's gonna be another thousand
yeah that [ __ ] right i liked that well i
loved it that i liked it
there was a guy one time
we saw him say we saw him but he said
you liked it that [ __ ] and then we
thought that was so [ __ ] funny and we
just kept saying it i've told this story
before and then we said it's it became
liked it did it i liked it at that movie
we started adding [ __ ] to it and i was
in a meeting
with this agent who wanted to sign me
and he goes you know tell me some of the
movies you like and i told him a movie
because you like that yeah i said yeah i
liked it i liked it i tried to catch it
i just saw his face like
oh this guy's dumb
when somebody when you see somebody's
facial expression change it's right here
yeah it's it's it's you know that thing
under the nba you know the nba with that
little three-second thing you can't
stand it it's right here
it's like it's the weird the eyebrows
very move but this [ __ ] furrows up and
it's one of those things you can't make
the face unless you hear somebody say
something surprisingly stupid and what's
devastating to you is you see the
respect leave them from you you just see
you see absolutely no pity for me he's
like this guy's done
a couple wrap it up questions all right
then later in the conversation you're
trying to say a big word you try to get
him back i don't chase it paul i go back
to the room
i chase i'm trying to say go to the atm
get in a thesaurus
i just lost i lost all day sunday i
gotta get the monday night game back i
gotta get it on monday night phone i
don't have it in me i just pack it in i
just go this guy's gonna get me a bunch
of work i don't want to do anyway that
is so you and me the difference where
bill will just put you you're the type
of guy you put your head down you live
to fight another day you go i [ __ ] up
me i do no no no no hold on i'll get you
back i'll win you back yeah i will be
back if someone thinks i'm stupid i'm
like all right cool
you're one less person i have to talk to
a laugh dude one time my buddy he's an
english major he's from out here uh sean
quinn right i haven't seen sean in a
while but oh there's another guy who
goes off i said something there you go
he applauds that's the philly oh good
for you you feel me good for you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
liar told me that one day some guy some
guy went some guy went in front dude he
put his half his body out he goes good
for you good you feel me you pieces no
but it starts off nice oh good for you
good for you you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
is great so this is how the [ __ ] this
is how dumb i [ __ ] this i said
something so dumb because it's not that
big of a where we're driving through new
mexico across country with him right he
was going to pittsburgh he's dropping me
off whatever
and he was yeah dude look at this like
this whole area over here is like
dilapidated and i go do you have to use
a big word like that which is not even
that big of a word just go and he goes
what i go did you have to say like
dilapidated to let me know that like
you're an english major and he just
breaks down how it's not a big word at
all and then i heard other people say it
and i was just like oh god that's a but
the lack of data doesn't know it's only
i don't know if i'm saying that right
but that's dilapidated dilapidated
dilapidated yeah keep saying it paul and
i swear to god i'll lose confidence in
it dilapidated say it dilapidated
dilapidated yeah the way you're saying
it's making me not it makes me i get
less sure of it every time i say it
but you try to blow through the word
zlatan neighborhood
but that's only you know you know who
does that bill you ever hear a host not
know the person's name start clapping
start clapping right now go to the
stages tony the santa
you sound like you do the intro like
you're driving by in the car like guys
this guy dude he just did this he's
crushing it right now start clapping
start clapping so you can yeah cause
you're trying to remember the name
adding credits
tony lisa
[Laughter]
no i've done that have you done it yeah
i don't i had like uh i had like a
complex where i was so afraid i was
gonna i was gonna forget the next person
because i would look i would look at you
i was so nervous when i first started
doing comedy as long as i've known you i
would look at you and i would completely
go blank on your name so when i i would
literally write if i started with you i
if i was hosting i would write paul
versi in my hand
oh cause you thought you were gonna [ __ ]
it up i'd be like that thanks a lot
that's what i couldn't do with the
handbag thanks a lot that's my time you
guys were great and then as they were
clapping i'd go
all right coming to the stage a guy i've
known for 15 years
you're getting nervous oh yeah no i i i
never like i could host now but i wasn't
good at hosting then because i just had
so much anxiety and the thing about
hosting is you have to go up and get
them and then you bring the next person
up you go off and then you got to go
back up again and yeah be like a tour
guide you guys are always going to be
great yeah then if if you kind of lose
them on one of those going they lose
faith in you and it's like anything else
didn't matter it's like you had a bad
game and you got to go back up again
that's how i felt if i would ever host
like years ago one time you know they're
like hey you wanna watch you host a
stand and i was hosting these and then
you feel like you go up and they hate
you every time yeah i i yeah i'm not
into uh
i i like hosting now because i like uh
you know seeing the younger comics and
all that type i just did montreal and i
tried to pop in on a show right and i
saw a couple of the younger comments
coming up i really like doing that and
on those things i like hosting [ __ ] like
that but i'm not into uh
you know i also want to get the [ __ ] out
of there i just want to go up
do what i'm doing that's another thing
too you get going and you're like oh
this oh [ __ ] all right i thought the
guy's gonna talk for a minute you know
yeah um
i'm sorry before uh before we get too
far in the podcast how many minutes in
are we
look at that huh
can a man feel a half hour can i [ __ ]
man feel a half hour okay here we go
uh roman everybody
you know when you're wearing a great
outfit
everything just looks right and your
confidence is soaring paul i don't need
to tell you that paul when your chain's
out oh yeah you're wearing yeah yeah
what's this yeah it's got to be what's
it paul you're [ __ ] feeling you're
crushing on the podcast even if you
didn't take it out the chain knows to
come out i'll tell you who's [ __ ]
with your chain game though oh is uh old
duggy there in left field for the red
sox
alex verdugo oh okay dude alex verdugo
could save your family with the chain he
has he could really pull a car of a
[ __ ] ditch what he has
uh anyways roman you can walk into a
room
knowing you're on an a-game uh if you
know when you're on your a-game if
you've been struggling with pe
the [ __ ] is performance enhancement
what is p
roman can give you that same feeling in
the bedroom
no erectile dysfunction yeah that's ed
what is pe
physical i don't know
hey there's some other [ __ ] out there we
don't know penis
enlargement
no it's saying you're having a problem
with it
we gotta figure that out
pe was physical education when i was
around this guy's beating up hey you got
a wet noodle
wet noodle almost just made me laugh
you got a wet noodle on a dry day
all right fitness
look we all know that changes uh that
okay fitness look we all know that
change doesn't happen without action
whether you're looking for gains at the
gym or a better experience in the
bedroom these guys are covering you
premature ejaculation premature
ejaculation
[ __ ] how do we not know that that's like
the [ __ ] family on on family feud ah
premature ejaculation will we come back
oh it's the sullivan family with the
chance to steal is premature ejaculation
mean like it but it's before it happens
right you come too quick oh it's not the
pre thing
you actually have you actually go you
actually come yeah it's basically
you're [ __ ] before she gets to wish
has any sort of pleasure
before a second but
like when somebody like there's like a
birthday and they come out with the cake
and before they get to the table it
falls on the floor you're doing that
with your dick
happy birthday
all right whether you're looking for
gains at the gym [ __ ]
or a better experience in the bedroom
you got a party hat on your [ __ ]
dick's just dripping everyone's
disappointed are they all there watching
who knows
um or gains in the bedroom there's never
any shame in showing up for yourself and
your health so if you're dealing with pe
don't ignore the issue instead face it
head-on with roman
all right guys man-to-man i care about
uh each one of you and i do to a certain
extent i'm not gonna loan you money but
i don't want you coming and dropping
your cake in front of your girl there uh
i want you to feel confident and to
prioritize your health and your
relationships if you're ready to do that
for yourself start with roman
entertainment paul this is the
entertainment section
paul we like to have a lot of fun around
here on my channel podcast show so i
know that if you guys are anything like
me you probably dread wasting time in
boring waiting rooms than having to
spend money especially if i'm there with
a bunch of pre-jerking
ejaculating and jerking
premature and circulation
even when you jerk off your hand bailey
gets on it oh what the [ __ ] that also be
weird if all of your friends had it
hey what are you doing here are you at
it too
are you bill's friend [ __ ] no i'm just
dropping somebody off i am too this is
why they do this you can it's it's
anonymous
uh you dread wasting time in boring
waiting rooms then having to spend his
pictures of [ __ ] dripping dicks on
the wall you don't be sitting there for
that long then having to spend money on
a co-pay then insurance is a hassle you
know you know how it goes for my guys
out there dealing with pe
premature ejerculation i have to tell
you about roman roman swipes are
clinically proven to clean up the floor
after you jitter
in front of your girl roman
clinically proven to help you last
longer in bed no prescription needed pe
treatments are safe effective and used
by millions of men
uh pre-two-day shifts you know what's
funny is sort of like numb you're like i
can't feel it again oh there it is
it comes to train
free two-day shipping go to get
roman.com
today [ __ ] dude
i wonder if you get used to those things
and then the first time you go to jerk
off without numbing your dick dude i
just started crying thinking about if
all of your friends had it like hey man
how'd everything go it happened again
[Laughter]
my wife is too hot
hey honey how about you [ __ ] put on a
few pounds and be a little [ __ ] around
here maybe i can make it through the
first two minutes all right look what oh
look who it is it's all zip uh
back up
uh talk about a person or people you
rely on to help you out with certain
things you know when i'm feeling down
and i don't know who to turn to i call
paul versey
you know i start bitching about whatever
i'm bitching about and he's right there
with me example a family member a friend
your partner
your co-host
personal assistant hey i'm not trying to
sell you your babysitter don't know
nanny no all right it's like if you own
an arrowing
a what
it's like if you own a growing business
the g thing got the the bottom part got
cut off
i thought it said an arrowing like your
archery
it's like if you own a growing business
and need to hire ziprecruiter makes
hiring so much easier because they do
the work for you and right now you can
try it for free at zip
recruiter
dot com slash bur uh ziprecruiter uses
its powerful technology to find and
match and the right candidates up with
your job you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite them
your top choices paul like a draft pick
additionally cscs
recruiter has that's the devil version
of it it was backwards okay has a
complete you don't know what the bid is
has a complete suite of tools you just
go okay
that makes it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates four out
of five employers who post on zipper
courier get a quality candidate within
the first two days no wonder zip
is the number one rated hiring site
based on g2 satisfaction ratings and we
all know about those things as of
january 1st 2022 in fact the hardest
thing you have to do to remember our
special
to do is to remember our special
ziprecruiter.com that's where you go to
try it all right ziprecruiter for free
once again that zip
recruiter recruiter dot com
zip recruiter spell out burp but you are
the smartest way to hire was that like
if the record goes backwards the double
thing or no yeah yeah
i didn't even know if you played forward
zip recruiter
all i know about that is i remember in
the early 80s friends would say they
would get rock rock albums and if they
went backwards it would be a message
from satan but yeah yeah but that's nice
it was really from the record company
and they were trying to get more stuff
and then uh
dude if you know seriously man it's
talking to you it's like judas priest
went to court for that really yeah these
kids did something [ __ ] up and then
they they they try to blame judas
priests rather than you know
i love your shirt dude by the way
anything better is coming back everybody
people are asking there goes it toast no
we took a little time it's coming back
yeah it's gonna oh dark days of summer
oh and nfl is coming a bill i had i had
a paul versey day today
okay yeah so
i got the car i'm in a rental
you know and i'm driving around tonight
you get some doughnuts i wanted to start
jerking off and put the doughnuts on
your dick i'm premature
ejaculation there's your frosting hey
when i see it glazed no
hey give me a jelly i can't handle it
okay there's so many problems with dicks
p-e-e-d yeah it's just gonna keep going
i remember one time i said something to
my dad or somebody i think it was my dad
or uncle and i it'll never
never nothing wrong
like it was almost like a little too
defensive
what are you [ __ ] nuts i can't get a
heart on it no you want to see it right
now i'll take it out
[Laughter]
my dick stays hard magic
my dick's always ready to go no so i get
nice
i don't think you could well you finally
get it out of heart
you finally did you finally got it game
when it was soft no right is it it
finally come
because
it's just like it was getting too
crowded in there what are you supposed
to do
it's so premature
it doesn't even
it happens on the train ride home you
just sit there you know ah [ __ ]
why did i wear sweatpants oh we're doing
come jokes
so
i get in the car
and i got to see what sneaker stores
have to offer out here i tweeted my last
tweet right now los angeles has the
greatest sneakers in america it's not
even close on my way here i stopped
i told stace i had to on my way here i
stopped
i got jordan threes
air force ones jordan three cements
jordan no a new one that just dropped
saturday it's a different color it's but
the three is the cements right yeah like
the third the the yes like the three the
ones that with not the four cements the
three cements you know them the ones
that i love the original threes yeah the
threes i got a new one a new one that
came out on saturday yeah i bought those
then i walked into a place but you don't
have these what is it what was it fourth
of july themed oh now we're into august
no no it's actually the theme that i got
was fall i wasn't saying it's fall i
knew it i was actually going to joke and
say they had like someone said cleavage
foliage no it really wow really because
it's orange and brown with this black
thing it's incredible i got that and
then i got it it's a whole sneaker like
that or is this accent no it's like
accents oh yeah it's nice you don't want
to overpower it's too much it's a
different type of look but it's sick
it's like blue cheese if you have too
much it's yeah yeah and then i got air
force once and then i almost bought
those are the up tops right uh yes yeah
yeah but i got a different kind that's
like a black guy's if it's raining out
sneaker
he just puts on his up towns because
they're not there but now there's this
thing going on where he keeps the other
ones there's this thing where white
girls are wearing the new thing is dirty
air force once and i can't handle that
that's a white thing it's a trendy like
a hipster thing is to wear beat up like
caked and dirt [ __ ] air force ones
and like even these rich cause it's
brutal do you know what's funny about
that when you become a slave to fashion
is that you would actually just like go
out and like deliberately try to get
your sneakers cool and then as a hipster
you have to act like
you know they were just like there's
nothing cool about not new to me
if nothing i need it out the box
gleaming white
nothing other than that
it's on your feet all right don't yell
at me it's on your [ __ ] feet what are
these people doing just saying you know
you know it's like wear a crispy [ __ ]
thing
have a little respect for yourself yeah
you're going out it's like what are you
doing dude put the chain out just spray
a cologne oh you want to left lucas give
yourself an at-bat
lucas has got lucas is into cologne
stacy goes yeah he keeps going he goes
dad i took it kid came in he had his
little chain out and he sprayed it i
swear to god dude he's in he's in dude
he's into cologne and [ __ ] the influence
you have on your kids is as long as
you're not an [ __ ] yeah you know he's
not out there backhanded women
no i said this i said this you gotta i
said this on stage the other night and
and the place went nuts and i said look
if you're a father and your kids don't
love you sports teams you love you're
[ __ ] up as a dad and one guy got so
he goes that's right he was like it's
like yeah and i said i knew kids growing
up that liked the yanks and the dad
liked the other or vice versa every time
the dad was a dick every time they get i
was like oh that's why that's why
because this guy's not being a dad to
this kid yeah that's a hard one to
listen to look at your daddy but i i
live in l.a so my kids this eventually
you know they're going to go to school
the other kids are wearing the other
girls that's a different that's an
exception that's that's a tough you know
what i do is i just watch the red sox
every night
and they always say who are you rooting
for them like the red sox they'll be
like which one's the red sox because
they're like 50 different uniforms now
it's going to be hard if they're like
the ones the yellow and blue the ones
wearing the red the ones wearing the
white the ones wearing the gray like
every night it changes your court side
at the lake lebron gives your daughter a
piggyback ride it's gonna be hard to
sell around the celtics after that
if he tried to do that if he tried to do
that it would have i'd hang on his leg
like van gundy
this ain't happening holding on to
oakley yeah this ain't happening [ __ ]
that that's great um
no i uh
i my son is like and daughter like
totally love my old truck
and uh you know there was a period there
when i was walking in
in the morning i always get my son in
the morning i go in to get him and i
would open the door and he would just
look at me and he'd have his head down
like that he'd go room oh that's [ __ ]
around like that and i'm like hey what's
up what's up buddy he'll be like daddy's
truck daddy's truck oh my god so what he
does that thing must look like a monster
truck to that dude that thing must be my
daughter said he goes to me i gave her
right and she goes dad this is the
biggest truck in the whole world that's
an 18-wheeler it's a two-wheel drive and
i think that truck's a little bigger
she's like no this is the biggest truck
in the whole world so my son
comes over you know
and uh he sees me like because it shifts
on the columns i gotta watch him reach
over he wants to start shifting i gotta
make sure i got the clutch in right but
he comes over and uh like he sees me
like i like when i when i would like uh
you know step on the gas
you know i just sit in the driveway with
it i can't drive with him it's just you
know you can't put a baby seat because
it's only you know uh it's a regular cab
so i just was sitting there going um
room and i would look at him he would
just go like that he looked at me and
he'd smile
he loved it so now what he does is he
stands up
and i gotta put i got it's three on the
tree so reverse is closest to you and up
so i have to put it in reverse so his
head can get by there and he's got a leg
what's that mean three in the tree
what's that uh you shift uh on the you
know you by the time i came around it
was it was down here right but i
remember my mom and then they won
yeah yeah so it was on the columns
there's three in the tree four on the
floor everything's [ __ ] rhyme back
then
so um
so anna was that was what cool was
before the internet so he comes over and
he like he like steps on the gas and he
always just goes like wow
and i always think it's going to scare
him and he looks at me i better just go
a little easier so i literally have to
put my foot underneath the accelerator
so when he steps on it i can kind of put
like a governor on yeah
you know use up like 10 gallons that'll
be their truck one day if you keep it
yeah
oh no no it is so i'm gonna uh
you know but that what made me think of
that was just saying like i like new
[ __ ] yeah like my car i've had my car
now uh coming up on six years and what's
great is the uh the driver's seat is all
like broken in got like the creases and
the cracks in it and then everything
else is pretty much especially the back
seat you never talk about that car
anymore to me why not i don't know i
mean i've never heard you you i hear
about the truck but i never i never hear
about you paul
i love that car i love that car you love
the jack take it back
what did i say don't buy anything
uh good color too you got a good color
yeah you got to do it you know i saw
something today me and femmles shout out
to andrew thomas i saw something today
it was brutal it was a beautiful big
brand new 2022 what's the boxy mercedes
truck the what's the one well the one
looks like a toaster yeah but this one
is like this one is like that one new
one this one is like that on steroids
and it was like sand color cream it was
beautiful and then i looked inside and
it [ __ ] was red it's a sin you know
if the white would have pop imagine that
if you opened up it was white that's
what i thought you were gonna say it was
no i'll tell you it was killing with the
colors toyota's toyota trucks you see
the desert sand they have yeah black
yeah [ __ ] sick yeah green they have
is great a lot of the japanese cars
right now are crushing it and i'm hoping
that they sell well any american thing
to say but i hope they do so these other
guys start you know opening up the
colors dude everything's black white
gray and this [ __ ] where you go out
and get a wrap which is you know that's
just
dude i'm going i'm going almost color of
that wallet is my dream so i want a
little darker than that like a chocolate
brown like like a dark chocolate brown
white inside that's the dream for me
that's the dream dark chocolate
hilarious yeah the first time it [ __ ]
rains and you're standing outside like a
[ __ ] homeless person i cannot get in
that dude i take the lexus to the wash
every three week every two every three
days stacey goes what are you doing they
just detailed it i go nah you good to
the car the car is good to you
you know she goes paul it's immaculate
in there i go
you know reigns yeah no it's that's what
you want no my car i got this guy i
watched on youtube where he finds these
bar barn finds and he buys them yeah and
these old cars and then him and his team
going to they literally have like those
masks that have like
you know like so you can you don't break
because there's usually uh a lot of them
they'll have like lead paint if they're
going to polish it and then there's all
kinds of like [ __ ] like mice and rat
nests and [ __ ] and they've pissed and
[ __ ] everywhere and you just look at the
car going like you need to just burn
that thing and this guy just [ __ ]
dude
oh my god dude it's insane like there's
two things that i've been watching i've
been watching uh
that guy's channel i wish i could give
him a shout out uh maybe we'll put a
link up i watched that and i watched
people power washing driveways
i just totally am totally into it yeah
i'm i'm obsessed with looking at tires
that are that shine i love seeing a
clean tire it's not weird yeah yeah
there's just certain things we're
basically two married guys we have kids
and we've just kind of left the universe
and we're gravitating towards the weird
things that we're into yeah no i i'm
looking at roofs and [ __ ] i look yeah
i'm really listening to indian music now
i'm [ __ ] loving it are you dude i
found these two guys just crushed it
well i found this drummer who was just
this woman was just [ __ ]
like
like just her whole attitude and like
how they learn how to play drums over
there is they're not counting right over
here they're like you know one and two
and one yeah
they they sing rhythms and they make you
sing at first and then you kind of learn
how to play so you're you're playing
from here and you're feeling nice
instead of being from here and i swear
to god i've
been listening to enough drummers that i
i can kind of
like with that sicilian versi thing that
you have they can be like this guy's a
selfish prick yeah i can kind of tell
sometimes when somebody is like uh i'm
starting to be able to do that like if i
listen to somebody where they're playing
from
wow if if they're playing from like uh
like what region like regional no no i
mean like if somebody just did something
that inspired an idea and they're able
to just do it
or if they were just like it's this time
of the show and i'm playing this on the
guitar i'm playing this in drums and i
do this every [ __ ] night or i knew i
was to do this four hours before it's
the weirdest thing wow you know what i
mean no but you kind of can watch comics
too where you can see sometimes when
they [ __ ] with the crowd you can kind of
tell like he said that line before
right he said that line before as
opposed to like that was right off the
bat right yes yeah yeah so i kind of got
into that i was trying to you know look
up
this this tablet drummond and just see
where this woman's like mindset was
coming when she was playing on the kit
because i just loved her playing and uh
ended up getting into like you just see
these two guys one guy with a tobler one
guy playing this giant flute dude if i
played this [ __ ] to you man if you ever
have problems like
you're stressed or whatever you got to
listen to this music or you just want to
chill yeah or uh you just want the
[ __ ] hair on your arms to stand
talking to you know i love to chill you
know yeah dude this guy i i i'll stare
at the trees and listen to it
that's what i was hoping we're going to
go do go get a cup of coffee and go
[ __ ] smoke a cigar but you got stuff
to do paul i get it paulie hollywood's
got a new uh
he's out here right i'm out got your jim
courier hat on yeah there's a reference
um
yeah nocturnal nocturnal admissions
right now it's on netflix on netflix
it's doing great thank you also can i
plug some dates no
um i'm gonna be
uh well all the dates are on
paulversey.com but if you're i'm doing
one-offs doing some one-off so i'm gonna
be at the washington dc improv october
19th i'll be at the best clubs ever and
then i'm doing the philadelphia punch
line the 20th the next night uh and guys
if you're in london there's a punchline
i'm performing in london for the first
time ever i'm gonna be
uh i'm doing something called uh 21 soho
it's a small room out there in london
october 7th hopefully i'm going to see
my giants beat the packers a couple days
later but get tickets it's a one-off
it's a small venue
it's going to sell out so get tickets
for that and everything else
paulversey.com check out the version
effect and anything better is coming
back i'm so psyched you're going to
london yeah i'm bringing and i'm
bringing my family oh and you know where
we're flying bill we're flying first
i'm gonna lose so much money on this gig
can you imagine walking to the back of
the plane with your daughter okay he's
gonna give you some
traveling and europe advice what never
connect through heathrow ever
okay don't ever do that in your [ __ ]
life wait but he throws where i'm flying
out of fly to heathrow the only reason
you would [ __ ] heathrow is because
you're going to london don't ever
ever [ __ ] connect to that airport
ever okay paul i literally got off the
[ __ ] plane oh he's into it i had to
go get my [ __ ] bag i had to leave
the innards of the airport get my
[ __ ]
stupid back when i used to check a bag i
had to go get that [ __ ] thing stand
in line go back through security again
where was your anger where was your
anger at that point dude you must have i
mean did you
or i i i
i had to accept it it was it was so bad
and i was with my wife i was just like
this is [ __ ] bananas
and like at one point i was waiting for
a bus like outside
outside like i was going to london and
this blue bus is something that pulls up
and just all these miserable people are
on it and you're just sitting there
hanging onto a strap and then you
[ __ ] get to another thing you had to
go [ __ ] security again it was
it was um it's just one of those things
where the airport was built
so long ago i think and it's london and
just air travel has so advanced past it
it was like it made lax look like one of
those little mom-and-pop airports it was
a [ __ ] nightmare but i'll tell you if
you're going to london and you just
[ __ ] land there we're going to land
there oh my god dude it's directed
i'll tell you right now speaking of
indian indian food is the [ __ ] there oh
indian food's the [ __ ] everywhere
underrated everywhere no but there
because they actually well they're the
ones that oppressed them
and came up with the caste system and in
destroying them
and and [ __ ] ruining so much of their
culture and everything they brought a
lot of it back including some people and
they cook their asses off for those
[ __ ] oppressive bastards wow
all right i'm going to eat it i'm going
to eat it
i love that what's it called yeah
what's it called what's that dish i like
chick i like the spicy chicken tikki
marsala is the white guy no no i like
the chicken vindaloo look at you chicken
vindaloo yeah it's a kick your ass
italian you're going off the menu okay
yeah
did you make me a little uh
i don't like the italians that go too
far though like they're like yeah dude i
don't get things from the menu you know
those guys no no i want the he knows
here's the thing
[Laughter]
if you're that guy just be that guy
don't tell me you're that guy because
then i think that you're insecure but if
i see i'm doing it i've seen italian
just come in and he just orders off the
[ __ ] menu that's one of those no but
if he's great things you'll see in a
restaurant yeah but if he does one of
these hey is the guy back there can he
can he do that's that guy's cool it's
the guy who sits down like you said and
like announces like i don't do that i do
that guy yeah yeah that guy's like it's
like all right buddy we know that's one
of those guys where it's the the the the
the depth chart
in his house goes him
his wife his kid or him his kids his
wife like you know you get married you
have kids you're at the third you become
you're holding a clipboard yeah i like
the older italian guy who goes like this
yeah does he mind well thank you i love
that guy yeah that guy's my favorite i
like
i want to see that guy in a non-italian
restaurant and just scare the [ __ ] out
of some [ __ ] northern european
looking guy like me
he's ordering off the menu a second hey
is he italian oh [ __ ]
hey what's going on
this guy's gonna [ __ ] destroy me all
right
we're out of time here paul i like you
know you're just [ __ ] you're crushing
it thanks man everybody's loving you and
you're staying down to earth you know
you get not buying too many things
you're flying first you're treating
yourself
it's all right with the food and the
travel i want it nice that's it are you
going to come by my house at some point
so i'm going to show you about the
converse that i got i would love to yeah
you guys love it you got to see those
paul it's uh yeah man dude i'll be
honest with you worked for you for open
for you for a while opened for other
guys for a while started headlining but
to have this netflix do this and it's
amazing and and i appreciate all the all
the reviews and everything and i knew it
was i knew it was doing well when the
bad reviews were like i like the lights
he walks too much i was like all right
it was they like
you know those [ __ ] finding something
but no it's been amazing so if you guys
haven't seen it man spread the word
nocturnal admissions i appreciate it
thank you all right the one and only
paul versi uh enjoy the music
picked out by the trust fund kid andrew
themalis and then we'll have a bonus uh
half hour of a thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
thank you so much for listening thank
you so much for watching hey anybody in
england go see this dude what's the date
again uh october 7th you got to go see
him and then i uh good luck to your
giants oh that's going to be great you
can see it see aaron rodgers giants and
packers in he's playing lynn
dickey phil sims all right man all right
we'll see you thank you guys
[Music]
all right hey what's going on it's bill
burr and this is once again time for a
very special monday morning podcast uh
you get an extra one this week
um and as always whenever i do that you
know it's not just going to be me
running my mouth i always have a great
guest and this time is no exception uh
please welcome the multi-talented the
multi-uh uh business owning uh from uh
entourage jerry ferrara man i don't
think there's any way i could live up to
that introduction she's talking about me
you're one of the guys that like uh when
i found out you won't you were co-owner
of that fat salad oh yeah uh which is
this great uh uh sandwich place out here
um one i found out that you were one of
the co-owners i was telling my wife i'm
like see that's what most artists don't
do they have all their eggs in one
basket i love the fact that you're
making money outside of this [ __ ] up
business so i joke with my brother all
the time it's like i hope one day when
i'm in my 60s you look back you know
acting was great we did great but you
know what we really killed
sandwiches that you know what you know
what i ate there
i ate there because of you your slogan
it says sows and then underneath it it
says we're making sandwiches all weekend
oh my god the guys if they when they
hear this the guys at fat sales are
gonna die they they're proud of that
slogan no i laughed when we me and my
wife saw it we laughed we're like we got
to try that place so of course i tried
it out and it's awesome but i'm 46 so i
can only eat there
so often but i close my eyes when i
drive past sometime i only want to look
at because it's on the way to the gym so
it's like i drive home i gotta pass it
every day i'm like you just worked out
don't blow it yeah it's on fountain on
fountain then you got the big flat
screen tvs you always got the game on
it's it's unreal it's like uh for
someone like me that's literally a moth
going to the light but the reason you're
here is um you actually you have a new
podcast coming out called uh bad for uh
bad for business yeah it's uh it's three
weeks old and it is bad for business
because i really don't know what the
hell i'm doing
okay
to you obviously for a while now and
i've i grew up listening to sports talk
radio i didn't have a tv in my room so
like radio was all i had stern all those
things so i just have had an affinity
for radio my whole life where did you
grow up bensonhurst brooklyn so wow all
right oh god what what sport
affiliations are you uh all right here
you want to know well you know nick's
obviously next week i don't have a
problem with that we saw that i don't
think the next guys yeah
you what you made the right choice what
could you say now though you can't even
really say anything anymore what could
you say you you went what do you mean by
that jerry like you're golden you're
good oh oh i thought you were going to
say that we're doing exactly what the
[ __ ] you guys were doing with buying up
everybody no i don't think so i don't
think so uh yankees no we should join we
did we did in uh 07. and look the minute
seven was a disgrace the minute we gave
jacoby elsberry money the to me it's
over the rivalry is over the minute it
started with damon a little bit like
that was yankee signed damon it kind of
ruined the whole
the whole thing they always go your way
though they never come our way they
always all throughout my life all the
way back to guys like bob watson there
was always just guys we let go and you
guys always signed it but i don't ever
remember
anybody you know even like an old lou
pinella we never got anything but we got
the old lou pinella or even like
mike peggy ruler like a rick cerone who
was really an indian like coming our way
we it always seems like they always end
up yeah you might have got one guy andy
hawkins who i remember the only yankee i
remember used to buy the helmets carvel
used to give an ice cream scoop in the
little mini batting house i remember
that yeah and i used to watch yankee
games and i'd write on the sticker and i
put the stats of the game on the back of
a sticker i still have this one helmet
andy hawkins threw a no-hitter and lost
to the chicago white sox five errors
four walks they lost three nothing he
threw a no-hitter
you were at that game no i wasn't i was
watching with my little carver i think
it was on the road against the white sox
and i think hawkins ended up being a red
sox for like a half a season out of the
bullpen that sounds like the kind of guy
that we'd signed he throws a no-hitter
police at least back then at least back
then we did but um i don't know we're
we're playing off i gotta tell you that
johnny damon that was that was brutal
and even though i know he was a what
kansas city and then he was in oakland
oakland and then we got him so i
understood
there was just something about like we
finally
beat you guys and that he was such like
the poster child of our team and then
just to watch him go get his shave and a
haircut like and get another ring like
he was going over his parents house he
went corporate almost it's like he was
wild shot he who had one of the better
beards and hair on the red sox like he
had his beard was phenomenal right and
he had like seven rbis in that game
seven he hit the grand slam yeah
so yeah that ruined it for me like that
really hurt the red sock yankee rivalry
like i to me it i my fondest memory the
ending would be like pedro martinez
throwing don zimmer on the ground that
was where it was at for me that was the
height that was the height
did that piss you off when that happened
or did you understand made me so angry
and then let me ask you this jay what
what the [ __ ] was he supposed to do he's
got this old guy running at him
all right he's got these are his options
he's in a no win either he runs away
from an old guy
okay that's one
two he punches him in the face can't do
that cannot cannot do that or
you gently take him by the side of his
head i feel bad now because he just
passed away i know and you just sort of
guide him to the ground that's what he
did i paid him he was in a no-win
situation there's no way on earth he
comes out of that where it's like pedro
you did the right thing he had no shot
he was the minute zimmer planted his
feet and charged pedro martinez was in
trouble still was not a uh
was that was not a good moment so then
football where you going to football
giants giants congratulations giants i
remember the greatest day of my life was
when the giants beat the niners in the
nfc championship game the leonard
marshall sack knocked montana out giants
winning almost ended his career almost
in his career and then my uncle took me
to see home alone in the movie theater
greatest day of my childhood
do you know paul versi
you got to meet him you guys
you like paul versi with hair
um i just did that for him if he's
listening um uh you know what's funny
like back in the day uh
when entourage was first coming out for
people who don't know
uh jerry by by name uh he played turtle
on entourage do you know i actually
auditioned for that did you that hurdle
that's yeah that's how wide the casting
net was before they they were throwing
darts yeah no and they got you it
totally made sense but um
yeah i was you know not like i'm good
now but i was really bad at auditioning
back then and i that was that was it was
a memorable awful one i can't remember
because it was so bad or because the
show went on to be a hit so there was
like the first season and a half i'm
watching it going like god every time
you they'd say your character's name
like i would just sort of think about
that bad audition going on son of a
[ __ ] i i haven't been back
i have not been back since but uh what's
the deal with that man i they i got
information here that maybe there's
going to be a movie no no we just we
just wrapped the movie a month ago we
actually had to uh postpone shooting
kevin connolly one of the guys who plays
eric on the show broke his leg while we
were shooting doing what i i was kind of
a part of it i've actually now told the
story a few times but
it was a party scene at the beach and uh
we had a cameo from russell wilson
so and i knew i knew this was gonna
happen they wanted to do a little
montage of us you know playing a little
tackle football on the beach
and i begged i said let's figure out
what we're going to do let's block it
out a little bit worse thing to do the
two competitive
below average athletically guys
say oh yeah him and i is to say hey
let's just turn the camera on and see
what happens and sure enough you know i
go out he drills me he goes out i tackle
on like the third play it was actually
the most harmless one of it all i
wrapped him up
he like tried to dive and extend the
ball over the goal line and just his leg
broke uh broke in two places did you
hear you heard it snap i heard something
weird it wasn't like the the paul george
awfulness it was not that thank god but
uh i heard a little something and what
did he did he didn't know he popped up
and he thought he sprained his ankle
russell wilson came over and said like
you better tie those laces tight and uh
he worked for like two days with not
knowing just and finally he tapped out
he's like guys i gotta go to i gotta go
to the doctor and they actually like you
have a broken freaking leg you didn't
surgery the next day what did he which
which bone fibula
fibula surgery screws and everything so
we had to shut down for a month but the
movie's done and i actually just saw an
early cut of it yesterday and it's it's
actually good oh i'm really happy i'm i
hate everything how do you deal with
that man like uh like i said the little
stuff that i've done
i i immediately realized how little uh
just little pow power you have if you're
just a performer like i always hear a
lot on set
like yeah it feels like it's going good
and then there's always that yeah man i
hope this thing comes together because
you have no idea
um
when you're doing it i think more like
the director and the people who edit it
they have an idea of the direction it's
going in but like i feel like if you're
just acting on it you're kind of in this
vacuum where you're performing with the
other people
and just hoping uh you're giving them
what they need i got a few things to say
about that one i think it's like a game
of opposites anytime i've been on a set
or whether it was like an episode of
entourage or even a movie set or
whatever it is when everyone's like god
this is this is great this feels great
right everyone's killing it this one
bill's killing it jerry's kill
and then you watch it and it's kind of
yeah and then i've been on set one of
the times like i don't want to have any
idea if this shit's work this is the
weirdest [ __ ] we've ever done i i'm like
crossing fingers and you watch it and
it's the best it's it's great so you're
not supposed to know that i don't think
that's kind of like in stand-up the
amount of times that's right well you a
lot of times you feel like you're
bombing and you get off stage like god
that sucks and then your buddies out in
the crowd going to people they were
dying laughing just some nights you just
can't
you can't hear it but in acting i have
like uh like i have total respect for uh
any working actor because that just
seems like the hardest i don't know how
you guys
uh get to a point like how you get you
get altitude in that career because it's
so [ __ ] competitive whereas like a
comedian as difficult as starting out is
once you like
build a following like say whatever i
went to an improv and i sold some
tickets like i don't have to re-audition
no that's it at the next club it's like
okay this guy sells tickets so then you
move up to this next level and just you
know provided you keep getting better
you know you you you have this thing now
you have this thing like say you know i
go through you know periods without
getting any acting work but i don't have
to go back to waiting tables and and all
that type of stuff did you go through a
uh did you have any like
get something really big early and then
that just that awful flat line for a
while i
my story is interesting and i'll give
you the quickest version possible but
you know i i i how sick are you telling
this no no i'm really honest
everyone no a lot of people think like
that i i kind of just showed up out here
like some meathead from brooklyn and
like got cast in entourage right away it
was you know four or five years now look
that's a short amount of time
but to me
young and competitive it felt like an
eternity and i i lived in this neighbor
you know in burbank for 10 years i
worked at every restaurant
when you came out 19. i came out here i
did like three episodes of king of
queens and i'm like i'm staying and i
never left so you were smart enough not
to go to college i i did i did my six
months at uh at a college of staten
island a very nice community college
back on the csi we said they don't have
a big student loan college of stupid
italians we used to say it stood for
every kid who couldn't get into college
right there now the school's it's
actually a great community college i
shouldn't really talk [ __ ]
but um
i didn't have any great success i would
always i would get an acting job that
would maybe last a month i'd make like
seven eight thousand dollars which to me
was a million oh yeah and i quit
whatever restaurant i work i'd live off
that for as long as i can and then i
just would go months without an acting
job and i'd go beg for my waitering job
back and that was my cycle for quite a
while
but even then even though five years is
quick to it's pretty quick but to go
through that
for five years i mean this this time you
know what they talk about new york if i
can make it there i can make it anywhere
but personally this town for me is just
way
way more like brutal weak yeah and
brutal i always feel like new york
there's always like there's an
excitement to that city where out here i
don't know if it's just the topography
but this is like desolate out here and
uh that sun beating down on you there's
no change of season it just feels like
groundhog day just every day
[ __ ] sunshine
phone's not ringing you know and i can't
get anywhere in my car when it's the
when it's great it's the best town to
ever live in when it's bad it's probably
the worst town to ever ever live in and
i always tell people
i always get a not offended but like
i've had a couple of people in the last
whatever year to be like what's like the
easiest way like how you get into acting
like what's the easiest way i'm like
the easiest way that's how you're going
to add you're going to post the quest
there is no easy way and it's designed
to make you quit
the
whole system is designed to make you say
i i can't do this anymore i'm going home
it's made to make you say that
[Music]
well let me ask you this being also an
uh
a transplant from the east coast do you
uh do you miss the east coast do you see
yourself ever going back are you kind of
settling in out here i've had i've had a
couple of different trajectories with
this in the beginning i hated la you
know meathead from brooklyn my accent
was 10 times worse than it is now
uh
then i guess as i got a little
successful too i got the hot the whole
good side of the town the weather's
great i grew to love food's unbelievable
it's it's it's great you and i sitting
here i'm drinking an iced coffee it's
great it's great it's great recently
though and within the last year i've
kind of gotten to the place where third
i'm gonna be 35 soon
you know my family's all still back
there my nieces and nephews are growing
up now they're like you know six years
old they're starting to get that age
where i could do stuff with them like
i'm saying maybe i don't need to be here
11 months a year maybe it's maybe it's
nine and maybe i go to new york for two
months
i'm starting to get to that point maybe
i go spend some some more quality time
elsewhere maybe i don't need to i'm
built up enough where
look if i really blow it at this point
i'm gonna have to have a serious problem
must have happened right so maybe i go
spend some time somewhere else i'm at
that point now it's recent i'm always
jealous weird i'm jealous of new york
guys because you can go back to your
hometown in the in it's still a big
industry town you can't come on give me
a little i i go i i would go back to the
suburbs of boston now i know that they
shoot some stuff up there but it's just
like if i went back there like uh
like you know what i really miss most
about living in massachusetts is just
going to a sporting event
where i'm not in enemy territory it's
like i left in 95 i was in new york
through the height of the curse of the
babe all of that that was a bad run for
you yeah yeah it was all of that and and
and aaron boone well aaron boone never
took hold because the very next year
like aaron boone
probably
it definitely would have been worse than
bucky dent had the next year not happen
right but what happened was they just
sort of tore the band-aid off like oh my
god that sucked damn we want it thank
god but where the the bucky dent the
bill buckner thing it just it just it
just kept like i remember i remember
like i was at a warehouse job
and it was like two and a half years
after the game and just one day in the
middle of the summer i was just saying
shaking my head
and my my boss was what's the matter
like you thought the count was off when
i unloaded this truck i was just like
dude i still can't believe we [ __ ]
lost that series
and he laughed the ultimate delay
no no i mean i had the reaction and all
that but just like years later you were
just thinking about it
it was just so it was so uh
like i mean i imagine as much as 04
would suck for a yankee fan because of
all that other success you've had and
then you won one afterwards it's bad but
it's not it's not as like uh like take
like you know i guess uh
i don't know cleveland fans or something
like that where it's just like there's
just no light there's been no light
that's bleak that's blue but now now
there's there's not light but at least
there's a little hole a glimmer of light
has poked through with lebron and maybe
johnny manziel but yeah it's huge i'm
hoping i hope he's going to be good i
want oh i'm a boy i think it's great
it's the new era and there's some
dinosaurs that are going to hate on him
for a while i i think there's nothing
nothing what about his size and those
all those guys who run around first of
all nobody's going to be faster or more
elusive at the quarterback position than
mike vick so if
if he can get caught he can get hurt
that's the only thing that i would worry
about but uh i'm actually a browns fan
uh
my my parents and some other relatives
have lived in ohio and now so you
legitimately root for the my
girlfriend's from ohio and i just went
there for the first time recently and
they are the most
passionate fans
obviously boston and new york too
i'm all boston teams by the way
i couldn't believe i liked the browns
because my dad liked the browns he grew
up in ohio and in michigan so every year
is going to be their year so he went he
he went to like all municipal stadiums
saw jim brown playing that type of thing
so that's amazing so he uh
he's got this weird i have this weird
thing with him he was a tigers and a
cleveland browns fan so i have like uh
an affinity for both of them and a
little bit with the red wings if their
fans weren't such dicks all the time
talking all this [ __ ] granted they have
all those cups but um
so i'm actually uh i'm hoping that that
he's gonna uh
he's gonna he's gonna do well one of my
prize followers on twitter i'm not good
on twitter but johnny manziel follows me
and that is one of my prize followers
i'm most proud of of that follow
um we actually me and my buddies when we
went to go see him last year at uh
amazing right next to alabama it was a
[ __ ] it was a it was just i'm going
to go to a browns game i think i'm going
to try to go october 12th i think
they're playing the steelers i just want
to go with it i just want to go
see what that's all about those fans i
just can't believe how hard they show up
and root and they haven't won more than
five games and
yeah they're they're maniacs out there
like that you would not want to walk out
there with the other person's uh no
jerseys i'm gonna go speaking of that
how do you feel about like uh attending
sporting events out here in la i mean i
have i personally i've not had
the best experience
unless you show up wearing their [ __ ]
which i'm never gonna do i kind of i
dress like a plainclothes cop when i go
to the game same here but like they just
take it way too [ __ ] serious out here
where there's there's always a little
bit of that uh you might get stabbed
like this about the dodger games
particularly or
chargers oh and then just [ __ ] i hear
about like dude some guy got shot at a
[ __ ] 49ers raiders pre-season i've
never gone
up to any north
no norcal sports like i've never been to
san fran yet since i've lived here oh
okay um i've never been to oakland i
need to go i want to go experience it
they're storied franchises they have
great fans yeah but you're not going
through the black hole watching the
raider game where in the charger i would
not i wouldn't do it i wouldn't do that
although like i i think the the raider
fans took a turn for the worse when they
started dressing up like characters back
in the day the crowding characters yeah
the crowd they all looked like they were
in a biker gang and they were like
legitimately scary but now it's like uh
i'm not saying like there's a lot of
people in that stadium could [ __ ] you up
but you got that around the league
but uh those stupid characters man with
the spikes coming out they look like
they should be going to comic con they
look like the i don't remember the movie
weird science when like the motorcycle
gang comes in at the end the crash
department they look like those guys
that always struck me i saw one shot of
a guy who looked just like one of the
weird science biker guys at the end
jesus christ dude you just took me i
know i went back i'm sorry i i do i've
been watching a lot of old movies um
well speaking of speaking of movies um
dude you're in like insane shape right
now and and um obviously i asked you
when you came in the second you walked
in i i had doubt written down here that
um you just signed on to play two-time
world champ arturo gotti in an untitled
biopic which i'm so psyched that they're
making this uh executive produced by
mark wahlberg and the second you came in
i was like are you already shooting the
movie you're just you're just training
at this point i'm training now and i'm
kind of getting ready i'm i'm not in the
full swing yet like we're actually going
to go have a training camp i'm going to
go up to big bear and do that whole like
24 7 thing no we're going to get
shredded i'm going to do my i personally
don't there's only a level of shred i
can get like there's
a mid-drift region italian from and also
i was 205 pounds i we may have to cgi
some [ __ ] with that i don't know but uh
yeah what you how tall are you
five seven if i have on good shoes and
you were 205
and what what is what is the weight uh
when you went to the doctor
why when you went to the document you
were 205 and says listen jerry i love
the show i'm not trying to be a dick but
you need to get down to what were you
supposed to be am i like the normal for
my height yeah one the normal for my
height is 150 i thought that would be
what the 1950s one for five six and a
half he was like 150 155 you'll be
normal
and that's actually exactly how it
happened i went to take a physical to go
do a movie it's like the hollywood
physically make sure you're not dying
they literally make sure your heart is
beating and that you don't have any
weird outward things they do the blood
pressure yeah they look in your ear like
my mom could do that physical for me if
she had to and the guy he was being real
thorough i'm like this guy's looking for
something to like fail me and he put me
on the scale and i just turned 30 like a
week after my 30th birthday
and you know the doctor wasn't trying to
scare me he's just like look you're not
in any physical
threatening life all during like you're
you're young still but you know what as
you get closer to 40 if you go on this
path you're going to be faced with some
problems so start now it's way easier
now than when you're going when you're
going to be 39. trust me dude trust me
and i just started
and uh it's been four i'm 30 i'm gonna
be 35 now and i'm i'm at 151 i'm in that
i'm in that range of i guess
the proper weight for my short ass
congratulations dude that's aw and how
long did it take you to drop all that
it's just nons it's still going on it's
just been years like yes you're doing it
the right way you gradually uh did you
do it more with diet or or working out
or both both but i mean at the time i
was still smoking cigarettes still i was
smoking pot still i i quit all that yeah
and um that [ __ ] by the way i'm 46 right
around 40 man i'm telling you like
there's this weird thing where at 40 if
you figured you started being a
knucklehead around 18 19 if there's that
tipping point where for more your life
you were being a [ __ ] yeah then running
around and riding your bicycle as a kid
yeah and all of that [ __ ] i'm telling
you it starts like the sh the weight
just [ __ ] you see it takes you down
and like uh
all of a sudden just some of the
conversations i'm having with uh some of
my friends it's just uh it's it's what
i mean unfortunately i never let it get
too out of control i'm about a buck 70
now the worst i ever did i went about 20
pounds and dude it was all
road [ __ ] wait you were up to 190
yeah i was almost close i was closing on
190
and uh
this comic keith robinson
i'm not going to say the comic's name
that he called me but he was a redhead
who was fat and he called me him that
day and it just
it it was funny as hell but it really
stung me and i was like all right
i gotta go because the one of the
running jokes on this podcast is that
i i think fat shaming works
if you're it you know like i'm not
trying to get in
trouble but it's just like i do that to
myself like i'll be looking in the
mirror when i'm just i go look what you
did you piece of [ __ ] and i just said
nobody should love you you know just
[ __ ]
it gets me like
i i just
i just have an unacceptable weight like
i'm not [ __ ] going past this buddy i
have a i have a photo album in my phone
that's like my my workout photo album
it's all old photos right that really if
i i look at it and it's not even because
i want to look a certain way because i
look it's only it's going to be what it
is bro i'm not a pretty boy
i i'm not i'm not a particularly
handsome guy
go [ __ ] yourself what you look great i
look at those 205 things and that's how
i'm like that [ __ ] if like i don't want
to go to this i don't know
were you were you out of shape as a kid
or the no no that just happened in your
adult life i always like
genetically we always had like meat on
our bones you know we're short guys even
my brother too but like i played every
single sport i mean i there was not a
day that went by in my youth up until i
moved out here that i didn't do
something that day sports wise you know
it's hilarious you're probably the only
guy who ever moved out to la in show
business and put on weight that's [ __ ]
unless you did it for a roll i i mean
um craft service got me i just went i
went probably from
21 to
almost 30 where i did not do [ __ ]
except [ __ ] i mean that worked and i
smoked and i ate
that's all i did so when you uh how old
were you when you booked entourage
23. going on close to 24. and that ran
for what seven eight seasons eight
seasons span the cross you know hbo does
it with a year and a half break so
spanned across a decade you know
basically yeah almost a decade oh so ten
years of craft service i mean that's
understandable you're kidding and then
you start making a little bit of money
you could actually afford to take a lady
out for a meal
yeah yeah yeah he went off the road
amazing what you used to think was a
good restaurant and then all of it you
know i used to be like you know like
going to the ground round was like a big
group
yeah and then then i made a little bit
of money and then what i thought was a
good restaurant and then the second you
know i met my wife then it's just like
yeah like jesus christ you're [ __ ]
everything changes kill me she she goes
on the internet and she knows where all
the places are and all that she's a
foodie huh she likes to not yeah yeah
she's good it is yeah until the bill
comes and it's just like jesus is this
like break a window it's not [ __ ]
worth enough we yeah we went out the
other every once like once a month i go
out and i and i uh and we'll go out and
it'll be just like some yeah it's
[ __ ] brutal if you can tell me
stutter and we just went out to a steak
place the other night it was [ __ ]
delicious but the bill was was really
into it it was really two
two people was like 280 something it was
it was brutal it was brutal and uh
i did i bring it up to her i think i
brought it up to it she got mad and said
it was tacky
i said when i was in ohio when i was
just in ohio we went to a really nice
restaurant and uh we went to the bar
first and we ordered around the drinks
for like four of us
and you know i get the credit card out i
only had like 20 i only had like 20
bucks on me my credit cards i go and i'm
waiting oh my god it's gonna be a credit
card situation it came
16 for like five drinks i'm like oh my
geez what it should be la women's six
thousand a sixty dollar drink order at
the minimum and i'm not a cheap guy but
it that was you know what they and they
used to be dive bars out here but all
the [ __ ] hipsters they take over
every one of them now the dive bars are
more expensive scale bars brutal it's
brutal so um i want to make sure that i
don't uh i don't forget to promote
everything so uh let me this this is
this is actually just for me
because uh like i was saying earlier
just as far as how you're making money
outside of this business i just think
that gives you such an unbelievable uh
amount of power where
if you have this income coming in if if
the acting work slows down just for a
little bit like when they come at you
and you know with the movie where you
got to be in drag you only have to do it
if you want to yeah we're like you see a
lot of these guys now because uh i guess
it's more before we talk about the fat
cells thing like
um
in your time in the movies like the last
10 years in the movie like the whole
movie industry now with the i'm not even
going to say the name of the websites we
can watch it for free
it's like it's doing to the movie
business what happened to the music
business 100
yeah so now like for you know people
outside the business listening right now
basically
how it works now is movies that have the
best chance correct me if i'm wrong are
like low budget independent things
or those hundred million dollar robot
superhero movies the in-between which is
all the movies that we probably grew up
loving you know the the stand by me
those coming of age kind of movie those
in betweens are almost not obsolete like
we don't enjoy them but studios aren't
making them right because their business
is like two three million dollars or
less
or a hundred million or more and that in
between gap is actually proving not to
to be the least profitable business and
i think those are the better movies
personally but uh you're you're
absolutely you hit the nail on the head
yeah cause i was sitting there one night
and i saw like the the probably like the
15th a-list movie star signed on to do a
tv series that's probably why all these
tv series are so unbelievable now it's
like something it's like it really is
like the second golden age of uh
television like some of the stuff that's
out there and i'm really far behind
people keep telling me i got to see
fargo and there's uh i'm we're i'm real
i'm i'm on like season three of breaking
bad oh yeah that's how far behind i am
oh yeah and like season one a house of
cards i'm real behind yeah i started
watching the killing i like that watch
the first two seasons of that uh house
of cards i watched the first episode i
was like i love this and then
you know my life got busy and i haven't
got back to that so uh you gotta pay
attention for that one you can't like
yeah the popcorn and you gotta like you
gotta lock in on that one you can't
really casually watch house of cards
absolutely so all these guys now you see
like i mean you see half the cast of
like uh boogie nights and all these
movies i love they're all um yeah on tv
now so um with it changing like that
that's why
um i love this this move i mean and you
did the most riskiest thing is
essentially opening a restaurant right
and uh how did that all come about it
came about because the uh the sal of fat
sals is a real guy he's one of my best
friends i know from new york uh we
always talked when we were young young
i'm talking 20 years old out here like
we need like an east coast kind of place
out here we didn't know what it was and
then obviously you know he and he's not
he wasn't in the entertainment business
so he's a mechanical engineer like
builds buildings
and uh he kind of ended that part of his
career and him and another friend of
mine came to me with this whole plan and
look i don't know i'm like paulie and
goodfellas like i don't know anything
about the restaurant business right
right i really genuinely don't i don't
cook what is that one for me i gotta sit
down and have to eat that's exactly how
that conversation went
and you know i they they're going to
burn it down someday and sal's going to
be [ __ ] yeah they're [ __ ] shocked
by lightning [ __ ] you pay me um
no so i i just i i invested in the two
of them i said guys i don't know about
food i know all restaurants most
restaurants fail but
um not that i feel like i owed but like
if i can't empower one of my best
friends because i'm a lucky [ __ ]
right now if i can't give you a shot
yeah why not it's
i went into it saying i'm going to lose
every dollar i so i wrote a check that i
was comfortable losing every cent of
right and sure enough the kid came
through and they i i look i don't run
the business right i'm not going there
making sandwiches i i'm in on everything
i know what's going on but they run that
show and they we just opened our fourth
one in austin texas dude you got to
update your bio you're killing it so
much they told me you had uh you had two
locations now you got four well you got
you had to be comfortable if your buddy
knew how to build and design a building
that he could make a sandwich i mean
that's got to be a joke yeah but he also
built out the places because of his
background and the other guy josh of fat
sals who he's the one that came up with
that we're making sandwiches over here
right you know he's been in the food
industry his whole life so they were the
team and i said i'm i'm betting on you
guys because the first one was at ucla
westwood great first location and i said
they have a great way of making everyone
feel like it's your spot like you're a
vip i'm like these kids are gonna are
gonna come to hang out with you two and
sure enough i hate to say i told you i
was right about that and then but they
they took it from there and have just
did you guys with that uh that flood did
anything come down your way no luckily
not ours but i mean we certainly felt
some of the effects of it but it didn't
it didn't hit uh our spot but um yeah
for people listening uh all over there
was a
water main break crazy crazy like one of
those 10-foot pipes you could drive a
truck through yeah uh broke yeah you
know it's not no big deal we just steal
the water here little things you know we
have so much water in la anyway so tell
me tell me about this i'm i'm jumping
all around no it's okay i'm
scatterbrained here but
um so this arturo gotti movie uh
now
is is this is going to be uh
it's going to go all the way obviously
going to go the the
i don't want to ruin the end of the
movie but i know how his life ends right
and and that's just really sort of like
open-ended as to whether
was it was it officially ruled like a
suicide it was officially rule of
suicide arturo gaddy uh
at the after he retired you know he he
went to brazil and with his wife at the
time they were going and the kid
and uh he was found dead and the
government there view uh ruled it it was
ruled a suicide she was his wife was
actually in jail on trial for the murder
and she was not guilty acquitted and now
she's back here um
you know while we will not be able to
literally make the movie and say
she killed him the goal of the movie
without giving away all all too much is
if we tell this guy's story correctly
you as an audience member will be able
to walk out saying there's no no [ __ ]
way he hung himself with a pocketbook
strap from the the staircase and ended
up under the island of the kitchen like
i have the reports it's it's
mind-blowing the the way they say it
went down
um so this movie's being made because
his long time manager to pat lynch great
guy he's actually in the documentary a
lot uh the gaddy ward tale the hbo
documentary that wahlberg voiced over
and um in the greatest fights of the
last man was that last century was
already the 90s like 98 no i think it
was it was early 2000 2002 was the first
fight and i remember i watched that
fight live was that mohegan's son
2 000 people there and jim lampley
actually says in the fight man he's like
man i bet you these 2 000 people did not
realize they were walking into maybe the
best fight they'll ever see when you're
alive
he was commentating the fight and he was
just saying he's looking around the
small little arena two thousand people
was like i bet the two thousand people
are you watching it on a big screen are
you at the [ __ ] no i was watching at
home oh okay here probably on break from
working at boston market stoned probably
watching the fight with some mac and
cheese
and um
you know so
mark played mickey ward in the fighter
and it's a great great movie and i love
mickey ward as well and you know they
weren't at a place really to get into
the gaddy ward stuff so i think this is
kind of that's why i think that's why
mark wanted to be involved is that's the
next step is showing that bromance the
ultimate bromance of arturo and mickey
ward right and there's all those movies
uh boxing movies is it's just i mean i'm
a sucker for those like that to me
that's like the modern day western like
when i was a kid i used to always watch
westerns with my dad yeah he loved those
and then um um i look the rocky movies
they started off good they got a little
they got a little crazy but but you know
what what was cool about the rocky all
of them was the premise of each story
like i i love i can't even remember
which one there was so many i'm an
expert talk to me
the restaurant
that was a little ridiculous but the one
where he's coming back like he's lost
all his money
uh
that is that's six
rocky five that's five so tommy morrison
yeah and that what i loved about that
i'm not saying you know what goes back
to philly yeah what up and what i love
about that one
is just the premise of it that they they
aged the character
with stallone like i thought they did a
really good job and they kind of did
like a good trajectory yes of it i'm not
saying they executed this is what you
got to do nowadays because there's so
many [ __ ] people out there that are
going to take new york you think that's
a good [ __ ] movie i'm just saying
like with the jump off point for where
they were going with that dude that's
hilarious you watched all of those
let's also take a moment and realize one
thing about how great how far we've come
if we tried to make rocky one now at the
love story part where rocky rocky
essentially rapes adrian
when he has her at the house
she tries to get out he slams the door
and i need the famous [ __ ] like he puts
his arms up on the pipe and the wife be
he won't let her leave she's trying to
leave she's like let me go and he's like
no you where you going no you got us he
basically date rape he doesn't let her
leave
yeah there's a lot now it's like dude
let her go there's a lot of that uh back
in the day i guess i shouldn't be
laughing at this it's just [ __ ] uh
just the fact that that one
what it wants
you won the oscar did also one i think
it won best picture best screenplay yeah
it was almost the sweep
jesus christ i forgot all i thought that
all that [ __ ] was in the future you got
to be are you a love sport
yourself where they'd slap the [ __ ] out
of them like i thought that that was
just in the 50s are you a sports movie
guy or no you some of them i like and i
i is if they're done in a way uh
if they're not too cliched it's very
hard at this point now it's almost
impossible i i didn't uh
i'll have issues like say a movie rudy
loved the story loved on all of that but
when you saw the actor they picked and
then the end they showed the real guy
you saw the real guy and even though
he's small you're looking like dude that
guy's a [ __ ] animal man i would not
want that guy running at me like i can
see how that guy had a heart of a lion
but just you know you know how hard i
would have fought if they were making
that movie right now to play rudy i
would mean sean aston head to head
battle i would have oh my lord steroids
for that movie absolutely
nowadays nowadays they're not that bad
one cycle i go with rudy every halloween
that's my halloween i gotta put on
another dame jacket that hold a bible no
you don't yes i do uh that's my go-to
that and schneider from one day at a
time
dude see so you basically you love
acting the way i love stand up
100 likes i don't know about you but
acting was just my way into movies and
tv i didn't i could have easily been an
editor and i would have been almost
equally as happy i wouldn't have had a
lot of cool stories that i have now with
acting but it was something in in tv or
movies whatever it was i just and acting
was what i landed on well speaking of
that type of stuff uh meeting all these
people uh all those years on all those
seasons on entourage who was your
favorite guest star because you guys had
some monsters on that show
god
it's written i know people always try to
take a high road they don't want to
single out one person i i'm not doing it
a
handful
i mean i i love james cameron only
because i think he like legitimized the
fake world that we created right like
james cameron on the show was directing
aquaman and so he like when he came on
he legitimized our fake world our fake
universe but uh i mean i loved like bob
saget we had the whole cast of full
house at one point
dice we had dice on there dice was great
ice was phenomenal
and uh just i never if you told me when
i was a little kid sneaking the dice
tapes with my brother listening to him
i'd be acting when andrew dice clicked
i would have punched you in in the nuts
no people don't understand like
the impact that guy had oh
i saw dice clay at the worcester centrum
this is like where like celtics could
have done a home game if they wanted to
i was like second to last row in the
upper deck
and he came out and destroyed and in the
end he did his impressions and then i
swear to god he played a drum solo i'm
not even lying like this it was like he
could do no uh
no wrong and it's so hard now with all
the internet and all the [ __ ]
podcasts and all this [ __ ] for somebody
to have an impact and and get that big
and uh that's one of the his son is one
of the best drummers i've ever seen his
son max you talk about you guys he told
me oh my god his son is on
real on the drums like we'll knock your
head off with the drums
there you go so you get an appointment
we've had so many cool i mean
i always describe it like this like we
had one day on entourage where i don't
think any other show would ever do this
on the call sheet
6 a.m call at 6 00 a.m we were working
with sydney pollock great actor director
and then after lunch we were doing a
scene with kanye west it's like wherever
are you gonna in one day
are you gonna do scenes with sydney
pollock in the morning and kanye west in
the afternoon it was that was the one of
the coolest parts of it that's awesome
how crazy is uh bob saget i love him i'm
obsessed with him and he did something
really cool my nephew who's now
watching full house my mom bought him
all the dvds it's his favorite show he's
five years old he he he he wants to call
me uncle jesse he asked me he's like i
call you uncle jesse instead of uncle
jerry i'm like yeah sure so i tweeted
that
and bob who uh bob saw you must follow
me and wrote like dm me like look if the
kid's ever in town bring them to fat
sows i'll come me i'm like bob if you if
my nephew sees the real he might you
might see the first five-year-old heart
attack of whatever
she might just fall on the floor
i did a benefit with saggett
last week and that guy he's out of his
[ __ ] mind he goes on stage
and he starts wishing the disease we're
trying to stop he's wishing the disease
on the club owner and it's the funniest
like five minutes i've seen in a while
and the crowd's all like uncomfortable
and squirmy there's of course a couple
of people that get it that he's just
joking around but he goes up and he's
it's [ __ ] he just goes up and rips so
he'll talk himself
into a hole and he's trying just sticks
no he just keeps digging it he he
doesn't try to get out he tries to he
goes he tries to dig all the way through
and come out the other side down in
china and that's what he did he felt him
going and he just kept he's he's out of
his mind
one of my favorite um
comics to watch because of that style
and then also because of all the people
that watched full house and they still
think there's going to be this and
america's funniest home yeah there's
going to be this
yeah this family sort of like
entertainment kind of thing last quick
bob thing and doug allen actually said
the creator of enter i said this on my
podcast when when he went to bob saget
to do the show
doug wanted to play bob as like broke
like broke like living somewhere and by
and bob's like look doug
i'll do any one thing i won't do i won't
play broke right because i did i won't
play so doug was like all right well
what about would you like to have sex
with prostitutes like yes eat done
easily but i won't play bro he would not
play down on his luck broke bob but he's
like i'll have yeah why not i'll have
sex with prostitutes yeah of course
because he just thought it was uh he
didn't want to do it that was like his
one i'm not playing bro because that
like um it just doesn't fit what i do
that's also that's probably a smart move
too because so many people would think
that he actually did that where if you
just do the prostitute thing like this
with his comedy a little bit i guess
like and if you if you know him you know
you don't really take that seriously but
you may be kind of wondering in the back
of your mind like wait maybe no he's
great you know oh jesus all these
memories are coming back i i was uh
i was walking my dog and there's a house
that i walked by that you guys i didn't
even realize i was watching a rerun and
you guys shot without ralph macchio
there oh god yeah yeah yeah i think yeah
kevin dylan too yeah that was um
and of course you know ralph was
hilarious and uh every time i swear to
god like i i walk by that thing like 15
times every time i go buy it i like nine
times out of the fifteen i'll be like we
asked him to do this macchio stood right
in there yeah we're going to do the
crease shut us down on the crane kick
what is that oh the
the famous daniel larusso crane kick at
the end that he hits johnny with we said
will you do the crank he's like no won't
do it and you only asked once right oh
yeah yeah out of respect of course yes
once he says no we we really tried
to never make anyone uncomfortable if
you if a cameo came on like they really
had control
of what how far they wanted yeah it was
never done with like you're in on the
joke we're not trying to make you look
like a dick if you're uncomfortable
either don't do it or we'll change doug
was always great about that that's
awesome well i had an awesome time uh
finally getting i know i met you briefly
but uh i'm really happy for all your
success here but we
didn't really get to talk too much about
your podcast what's is it just you is it
gonna be like another uh it's it's just
me but i do i do have guests uh a lot of
heavy sports i'm going to begin it is
you know i'm trying right now not to
because it is the dog days of summer and
you know there's no football there's no
hoops so
i'm rea i'm every time i uh every show
at some point i say i'm not going to
talk about sports because the minute you
know october comes around it's probably
going to transition into that a lot oh
absolutely so
but we're doing some fun sports things
uh we got like the sports academy awards
i'm doing this one thing where uh
we're gonna do the best sports movies
never made
so and i want my audience we're going to
just listen to that well i would love
for you i'd love to get your take on
this too don't
we're going to cast the 86 mets
that movie oh jesus let's cast
but i'm saying i'm doing that one on the
on the show next week i think where we
cast the 86 mets a little teaser you
know
denzel if he was a little younger would
have been a great daryl strawberry i got
the best daryl strawberry who had this
little t this i'll tease it with this
one all right to me it's a genius call i
don't know how you're going to react and
only because of what he looks like now
okay dave chappelle is daryl strawberry
because he's jacked right now isn't he
the pictures i've seen of chappelle he's
like yeah yeah huge no i saw him when
he's in seattle he is he's like a big
boy yeah i would guess he's gonna throw
it across the room at this point i would
cast him as daryl
oh but we could have fun with it we
could have i mean lenny dykstra who's
gonna play lenny dykstra mookie wilson
dwight goodin
keith hernandez these are bringing up
some bad memories you know i wish we
wish we didn't play them in 86 is i
really would have enjoyed that team more
because uh i saw so many things on there
just the unbelievable like the just the
level of talent that was on that team
was was was insane and uh
you know obviously what happened when we
ran into we had those [ __ ] beat oh
that book too if you ever want to read
it dude i watched that so little i i
don't even remember the names like i
can't even remember who was the guy who
ran across the home plate and he put his
hands on his helmet like that was lee
missily
why did i think it was night i'm
thinking maybe it was maybe his night
my initial mine is telling me mozilli
but that's not a fact behind the bag
blackness yeah everything [ __ ] showed
that forever it made me i still love
vince scully but every once in a while
when i'm watching a dodgers game
listening to him his voice will get up
into that register and that's all i'm
hearing could you imagine and then
matching what happened now with social
media what the hell that would that
would set social media on it would break
twitter if that happened right now
twitter would have to shut down their
whatever i don't know anything about
technology but whatever they use that
[ __ ] would break if bill buckner
happened right now oh and he like uh
bill buckner actually back then before
social media he had to leave yeah boston
and he you know he was upset and he
talked about it too and i was kind of
like i felt bad for him on one level but
on another level it's like dude
you know
what what do you we haven't won it in
this long
what'd you think was gonna happen
it hit a pebble or something i don't
know what's that but you know when it's
a little slow roller
what do you what do you think did he
expect compassion
i don't know did he really expect
compassion well i know you should get
some compassion for his [ __ ] bob
stanley that's who should give him you
should send him a [ __ ] card every
every week that he took that off for him
or whoever was i see i i haven't
literally have never i never watched the
game don't go there no there's no reason
to go there one time i watched some
highlights and we had that calvin
cheraldi in there and it was just single
single
single don't go out dude it was it was
the sickest thing you're gonna start
getting cold somewhere no no no no but
it's fine because we won all these
championships but it's there's just
something about that one that one hurt
that was because i was 18 when that
happened
when
bill buckner happened i was 10.
so i didn't even i mean i didn't even
know that we hadn't won it that long and
i didn't even i knew the yankees had won
some championships but i was too young
to get it but by 86 i got it
and uh you know you think the celtics
won it that year
patriots went to the super bowl we got
the [ __ ] kicked out of us right but it
was looking good
that was foreshadowing
our this past tenure we kind of got it
all at once but um but anyways hey i'm
i'm really happy for you man all this
success and like and it it the highest
compliment man you know back in the day
you know it was really hard to to go
from a television show where you were so
known as a character especially if they
had like a nickname or something like
that to then to be going on to doing the
stuff that you're doing you're playing
this arturo gotti i think it's gonna uh
lead to great things you got all these
sandwiches places you're killing it and
you got a podcast and i'm helping you
promote it on my own podcast she was
about bad for [ __ ] business
that right there i cannot thank you
enough though for having me i've been
i've been a fan for quite a while i
actually when i when i met you that
night the knicks screening we saw a
screening for the knicks files oh i uh
uh michael michael right before it's
finally directed uh and which is great
by the way yeah it's it's awesome what's
it called again uh when the garden was
eaten yeah which is based on a book
right it's based on the book when the
knicks were actually good which i i
don't know see it's similar to you like
you're i'm like that with the knicks
even like i just have no idea that
they're just losers to me but you
weren't you're well enough for pat riley
that was the early yeah but yeah you
know losing game
game six and seven to the rockets john
starks going two for 17. the joke was
john starks tried to shoot himself after
the game but he missed oh you know it
was uh that was my gen patrick ewing
missing the finger reggie miller scoring
eight points in 20 seconds
yeah i i feel your pain oh sorry i'm
glad you know what if you're a fan long
enough you got those [ __ ] stories
yeah yeah but anyways i hope uh what
little i can do on this podcast i hope
makes bad for business
uh a big hit out there and uh
congratulations on this a tour gotti
thing man i can't wait and uh i'm gonna
hit your uh fat cells pretty soon oh
you're vip now bill your vip now all
right jerry thanks a lot thanks man all
right